los saludo desde acá desde el capitolio
cerca muy cerca estamos de dónde va a
ser el evento de inauguración las
políticas a destacar son varias 15 que
firmarán las primeras obras una vez se
instale como presidente de eeuu de las
próximas 4 4 4 años las más importantes
lo que tiene que ver con el quabit es
una iniciativa que quiere avanzar el
presidente joe biden queremos nombrar a
alguien que esté reportando
constantemente los cambios y los avances
en esta materia después está ataca que
es la acción diferida para jóvenes que
llegaron acá cuando eran niños
inmigrantes eso es un punto muy
importante teniendo en cuenta la lucha y
el sufrimiento de estos jóvenes por pues
en la incertidumbre que tuvieron durante
los cuatro años de donald trump y
también está pues que va a acabar con el
tema de la no permiso de entrada que
tenían los inmigrantes de países
musulmanes